oh my god you're blowing my mind today
yeah and your eye and everything come on
what you got
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today we're joined
by jack harlow
he's a grammy nominated rapper and
founder of the music collective private
garden check out his debut studio album
that's what they all say which is
certified gold and available now
jack harlow welcome to the show thanks
for having me this is a dream come true
like i was telling you
i've been manifesting this for a little
bit my best friend's uh
my best friend's in the green room and
y'all have allowed him to eat
lockstep with me so he has a set of
wings too but he he put me on the show
like four years ago
he's like yeah one day we got to do this
and now to be here doing it
thank you
[Music]
all right well you ready to get started
with this one can't wait
that's what y'all do huh y'all start
somebody off real like
trick them into thinking it's gonna be a
smooth ride
and then and then it drops yeah yeah
yeah this is genius because this is
light right here this is something real
light
so your genesis as an artist really
reminds me of the old school rap
blueprint more so than the out of
nowhere success stories that you hear
about on the internet these days you
know touring your mixtapes
selling and pressing your own cds in
school and then building up a local fan
base and on your song
rendezvous you rap about being eight
deep at the show it might only be eight
fans
thinking back on those early days of
touring what would a nightmare show look
like like what is a show that you
remember as being a real character
builder
huh so glad you asked and character
builder is a perfect way to put it it
felt like
at one point on my gazebo tour night
after night
i was getting character builders but one
that stuck out was the first night of
the tour which really set the tone for
my expectations it was birmingham
alabama
there was as many people in the crowd as
we had come to the venue with
and like a lot of the nights like i
liked everybody i brought to mob behind
me staying behind the dj booth so
we were literally just looking at the
same amount of people so i had some
humbling shows but they prepared me for
this because i had to i had to show out
so i think it made me a better performer
but i had tons of
tons of shows like that is it true that
you made a song with your 6th grade
teacher mr swain
what are you narwhar here we go
oh my god you just blew my mind fam
um mr swain
i can't wait till he sees this yeah it
was my science teacher
he was really into rap and he was into
the fact that i rapped and i was his
student aide so i had a whole period
where i would come and
help him grade papers but really we
would just chop it up
he was cool as hell um wow
he just brought a smile to my face
brother he just warmed my soul up
that's delicious that's just plain good
so alongside rappers like action bronson
and lil wayne i'd characterize you as
an artist who has some of the best most
obscure sports references and you have
to be
the only rapper ever to name check nfl
analyst adam schefter
when you reference a name like that is
that a tip of the cap to that person or
is it just a name that fits a particular
rhyme scheme
uh it's both adam schefter is like big
salute you know i like to reference
things i grew up on and
you know just like somebody i love for
real and i love adam schefter like i
think he's a dope analyst and
it did fit the rhyme scheme but i was
like damn this is gonna be fly because
it's gonna be
it's gonna be a little esoteric you know
if you know you know
he reached out to me too he messaged me
he said his kids showed him they're fans
of me and they were hyped about it
i feel like this heat is creeping up on
my veins
hold on and then what in your opinion is
the most clever jack harlow sports
reference
i really like the route 66 on the i
really like um
know my name ring a bell like raja from
the city like rondo rajan
but i'm from the white side like hassan
i feel like that got slept on i mean
people know about it but like
i freestyled that too i was in the booth
i was in miami
and i did that line off the cuff and i
remember one of the greatest thrills
when you're recording is looking through
the glass and watching the people you're
with react to the things you're doing
live
and that's when it becomes a true like
performing aspect that's when the swag
comes out everything and just when i
said that line
and everybody there was like
just hard and then i got to see hassan
react to it in a post-game interview it
was dope
[Music]
no i can't hit them but it's hot
how you doing in there herb
this is the hottest one that far pretty
sneaky too for a three spot
this season that's real it's delicious
too
i think i'll take another bite so i read
a fascinating deep dive analysis on
billboard hits over the last 20 years
which concluded that
songs and song titles have gotten
significantly shorter in the internet
age
i've met artists i've met artists
who obsess about industry data watching
and then others who don't care at all
where do you fall on that like are you
somebody who dives into analytics and if
so what information
interests you sometimes what people are
reacting to
i don't want to get too mathematic with
the music because
i'm always trying to push for a feeling
and if you intellectualize it too much
like
you can go in there and suffocate it
without a feeling
so that's why you know this stuff
interests me but
i wouldn't say i'm somebody that's like
keeping up you know what i mean
you're an artist who seems picky about
production what are some of the
non-negotiables or specific things that
you look for or listen for when you're
picking out a bee
you're a damn good interviewer
i'll take it i think what you grow up
listening to
affect the choices you make i have
certain grooves and tempos i'm attracted
to that i think people can see patterns
in
but i love groovy stuff that's one thing
i could say i love things that
just got more of a spin to it as opposed
to like an up and down bounce
i like more of a groove you know what i
mean just smooth stuff that's what i
really like
what's the secret to a good hip-hop
ad-lib and do you have a personal
favorite of your own
the best ones come totally instinctually
so
you listening back to the verse and you
listen to what you said and you're
reacting to it that's all it is so i
think that's the real secret and just
finding those pockets where it makes
sense like i'm
i don't think there's anything wrong
with it i'm not someone that loves
putting ad-libs over top of my vocals
and so that's why i don't do a ton of
ad-libs but i try to pick them where
they're selective just
stuff that makes sense but i have
go-to's my fans always say
oh i do a lot of that and like i like to
do like percussive stuff like stuff that
just kind of like sounds like a high hat
or airy stuff just like little stuff
that just
decorates it a little bit you know what
i mean i know what you mean putting the
sauce on it speaking of
are you ready to move on here to the
next one the los calientes barbacoa oh
yeah
delicious my lips are hot might be the
best tasting one
damn jack of the four we'll take that
you are funny
so you are as you put it a kentucky boy
to the death get it through your head
till it's [ __ ]
embedded so as to my knowledge the only
person that we've ever had representing
louisville
we're hoping to get a jack harlow city
guide to derby city directly from jack
harlow
the louisville slugger museum overrated
or underrated
underrated that's how i feel so if you
went to public school in
louisville you took field trips there
and you'd walk out with a little mini
bat
so i got a number love for the slugger
new zoo
which is the superior regional soda ale8
or ski
hey late easily i forgot what ski was
when you first said it
it's coming back to me now but l81 is
he's gonna love that my boy in there
listen he's a la one stan
um yeah i grew up with la one in the
house so my dad had bottles in the
fridge
which is the superior annual event for
castle or the great steamboat race
it depends on your interests i suppose
if you're a steamboat enthusiast
it goes without saying but forecastle
for me i mean like i grew up going to it
and wanted to perform at it and then i
eventually got to so
hometown festival is special who's your
all-time favorite university of
louisville basketball player and why
terence williams alpha dog confidence
just a fly player
like athletic he had a good body his
physique was fire like
just a prototypical small forward build
i just thought it was dope
all right jack are you ready to move on
here halfway mark
ginger goat here in the five spot and
you're doing great
ginger goat eh let's see what this is
heading for
[Music]
must be ginger in there for real huh
i bet herman's liking that
okay jack we have a recurring segment on
our show called explain that graham
where we do a deep dive on our guest
instagram pull interesting pictures that
need more context so we'll put the
picture up here on the monitor
you just tell us the bigger story do you
have a favorite piece of memorabilia or
frame plaque on the wall when you
visited hitsville usa
i think i saw the tracks in my tears
plaque in there i just liked how the
plaques
looked a little different from how they
look now they were a lot more stripped
down and minimal
yeah it was just dope to see how plaques
were they're so dressed up now you know
they have pictures and frames and
the other achievements included and
spotify stats on them and stuff and it
was just like
boom plaque fact over with so it was
cool to see those
all right up next here you are with cole
bennett happy birthday cole
what's today is it really it is shout
out to cole shout out lyrical lemonade
what's special about him as a music
video director like why is he so sought
after by so many young artists and
hip-hop
for one he's a taste maker so his
co-sign means a lot and he's broken a
lot of artists but aside from that you
know there's some real talent there he
blew me away when we shot this video
not to say that i didn't think he was
talented before we did it
but admittedly i think i was more
intrigued by the platform and then i
actually worked worked with him
and he put the was popping video
together and it was the first video i've
ever gotten that
i got the first draft and i was like i
don't even know what to tell you like i
don't have no no i'm a note person i'm
very particular like
you're calling me picky i am so he sent
me the what's popping video on the first
draft i was like this is gonna this is
gonna change my life
i could feel it and it was crazy so he
just has a vision man he's talented
um quality individual happy birthday
something light y'all better turn these
up man i'm feeling good
you are a good man you say that now
you know i'm just trying to convince
myself of it
because this is hot
none of that i can't bear it up okay
i'll take another bite
so you once tweeted y'all really don't
know i'm a cenophile my final form is as
a rotten tomatoes writer
how do you think being an artist
yourself might affect your perspective
as a movie reviewer like do you think
that as someone who's had their own art
dissected by music critics
do you think that you'd be more
deferential to filmmakers or do you
think you'd be a savage in the reviews
huh i love a question
i'd like to think that i would take my
perspective with me
sometimes when people talk negative
around
sometimes when people talk negative
about celebrities around me
or they speak on controversies and i
have an opinion it irks me because i
know how that feels
so i think on a similar note i would
take that with me with that i would be
like
i would think about what it's like to
create because sometimes i do look at
critics and i'm like
what a [ __ ] you are like tell the
critics shut up like my show is on
yeah i'm like it takes no bravery you
know to critique
to say it's not an art but
[Music]
oh god wow creeps up on you
which jack harlow single do you think
would make for the best short film
adaptation
this should have been a first-wing
question what the hell is this about
that's how we stack the deck that's how
we stack the deck jack it's becoming
more and more genius i'm seeing the
system
adaptation of a song
[Music]
four left eh four left
are you ready to move on to that next
yeah [ __ ] the short film talk let's keep
going let's just gas pedal gas pedal
yeah wait till the next one
it looks bad i don't like the complexion
of that one
[Music]
so a lot of debates about the best mcs
center on bars
but a voice is also a major factor in
which rappers separate themselves from
the pack
and i've heard you attribute your own
breakthrough in the game to finding your
voice
can you talk through that evolution
mystery bro that milk is not like that
yeah almond doesn't quite hit
it doesn't um
yeah i think
one i started before i hit puberty i
started literally recording into a mic
so
i used to get made fun of because you
could tell my nuts hadn't dropped my
voice was so high
[Music]
and um so the shift i got really blessed
going into puberty it got deeper
i remember andre 3000 talking about how
he was with somebody in
organized noise and he was in the
basement he's like bruh stop doing that
rap voice
just talk just say the lyrics just talk
them
he said he went in the booth and he
changed everything for him he said
hey click that's kind of what's
happening for me and i'm learning to
fine-tune it
because i don't always want it to be
conversational you got to inject energy
in the right moments but
i found when i started talking the way
i'm talking to you on the mic
it worked wonders too much of an
inflection is hard to buy into
and you know it's not uncommon if you
dig into the crates for a lot of a lot
of mc's their early work you'll
oftentimes hear a higher pitched tone is
there a reason for that
so i think a deeper voice can represent
comfort your comfortability on the
record
i'm around 2018 people started to say
you sound so comfortable you sound like
you don't give a [ __ ] on the song
earlier on
trying to prove something you're in that
nasal zone you're
you're up here like chip on your
shoulder talk once you're getting that
covers on you just
talking
this next one is the bomb beyond
insanity
hey man don't be target like that it
looks like a problem look at this thing
yeah starving herb
seven
[Music]
immediate
that boy's disrespectful that is
disrespectful right there
[Music]
does it hit you different do you get to
a point after doing this that
it's not as hot as it was the first time
so i think you know
i'll know what to expect i've eaten this
wing for the internet's amusement
literally 200 times over the last six
years
so it's not something that i'm not used
to i don't expect
but you never get used to the bomb
beyond insanity
every episode is a labor for me
for the record can you describe your
relationship with ranch i saw that you
had a whole ranch flavor i wish i had
some right now brother
i love ranch could use it right now
don't know why you didn't have it
well you know when joey diaz was on the
show he brought blue cheese and he draws
a very hard line in the sand
about how much he cares about blue
cheese meanwhile when vince staples was
on the show he brought his own bottle of
ranch
do you think that there's a need to pick
one side of the other blue cheese or
ranch or can you go both ways
hey bro this is not even fun bro yeah
this is not even
careful around your eyes
[Music]
did you catch it i don't know i don't
know
yes you want to take a break no
come on hell yeah i said i was gonna do
this
i'm not gonna look at you but i'm gonna
do it come on i got you i got you blue
ranch ranch ranch
that's what you got oh my god i tried to
open it bro
what's special about the applebee's on
bardstown road and the highlands
this tin you can't even tug on my heart
strings right now brother
that would have three wings ago that
would have made a lot to me
are the other two hotter so here if you
can handle that
you can handle any wing you can handle
any wing dude
do you want to gas pedal it to the next
one no let's talk about applebee's come
on okay let's talk about apple we should
go in there
we should go in there and get these
decadent shakes and that's not my
adjective that's what it said on the
menu
we used to get these shakes after school
after football games we just been to be
in the booth tormenting this staff
uh fourth time
oh i can't open my eyes bro it should
have been a conversation about not
touching eyes
i know it seems like common knowledge
but damn i should have known
it's only painful it's not dangerous
right all right so this next
i got one for you my lazy guy too i
can't [ __ ] see
well this next one is birth go ahead if
you can't with the eye patch you used to
have the eye patch over there
you're on your [ __ ] you are a man
my god you're blowing my mind today yeah
and your eye and everything
huh come on what you got so this next
one is the
is the scorpion disco in the nine spot
what a [ __ ] baby
oh my i gotta stop looking at things
yeah you want me to eat this for
only if you do
oh my god
so know that video games have been a
part of your life since the very
beginning back when you used to record
your earliest tracks on the usb
microphone that they give you with
guitar hero
and you're featured on that call of duty
trailer where you crash a helicopter
with
ac dc's thunderstruck driving the
background music
how do you distill the experience of
doing your own stunts
on that shoot well they put me on a
cable
with drewski and that was a unique
experience to be able to say i did cable
work
lifted me up dropped me down green
screen
it was overall a wonderful experience is
there an on stage stunt that you're most
proud of like
a balcony dive or crowd surfing episode
that that you remember like it was
yesterday
one time on stage dove i did a show when
i was a senior in high school and i sold
it out like a 300 cap
and i dove off the stage but the
stage was three feet tall i get i hurt
this girl's head
landed on her i felt bad she wasn't
badly hurt but
it was like a bad attempt i haven't done
nothing since no reckless
all right jack carla what do you want
come on
this is the last dab we call it the last
dab because it's tradition around here
to put a little extra on the last wing
you don't have to
if you don't want to i want to
oh
whoa i won't eat all of it
please don't was there a dab or a lot
yeah that's a lot that's a lot that's a
lot
all right brother no one's gonna tell me
i didn't go through this you went
through it
like a soldier
and thankfully and thankfully jack
harlow
we've reached the epilogue of our spicy
feast together we've talked about your
career
the xenophile side of jack harlow and
your love of ranch
hey but i know that no matter where this
industry takes you
forever your home will be kentucky so
with that in mind i want to play a quick
name association game where i'll shout
out some of the sauces that we've had on
the gauntlet today
and you just tell me the first famous
kentuckian that comes to mind
scorpion disco jennifer lawrence
the last dab of apollo the one that you
just ate johnny
just sounds classic the bomb beyond
insanity
static major recipes and then the
classic
george clooney well there you have it
a gauntlet for the ages with jack harlow
somehow someway he made it through all
the way to the end and now jack there's
nothing left to do
but roll out the red carpet for you my
friend this camera that camera that
camera
let the people know what you have going
on in your life you see it
you see it cyclops
listen man that's what they all say my
debut album out now
no regrets i'm happy i did this it's no
[ __ ]
i thought it was gonna be i thought it
was gonna be less than what it was
it's everything more
great job great job
i got my best friend in the green room
he
when we were when we were still in high
school i think he showed me this he's
like man one day
you gonna do this i'm talking four or
four years ago maybe maybe five i don't
know
right around when this started he's like
one day we gonna do this
and i said okay when we do it you gotta
eat them with me so i think they're
taking him
some wings in the green room to eat and
live stuff with me so this is
i really want to say like this is a
dream come true for real
we manifested this moment so i'm really
excited to be here i'm happy that i can
share it with you hell yeah
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is shawn evans checking in with a very
exciting hot sauce update
los calientes barbacoa it's finally here
baby this sauce right here
evokes all the flavors of barbecue but
then with a smoky mix
of serrano and habanero chilis perfect
for slow roasting meats
perfect for slathering on burritos
grilling vegetables
get your hands on los calientes barbacoa
heatness.com
heatness.com to order
all summer long we're having the remix
of the remix
hot ones barbacoa the unofficial
official sauce of grilling and chilling